you
hello i'm chris grinning from the
quantum
and computation group here at Microsoft
and today I'll be talking about the
quantum development our recent effort to
empower people to get hands-on and
learning with quantum Albert quantum
programming and at a high level there's
a number of different pieces of the
quantum development kit including
comprehensive documentation to help you
get started but the most exciting piece
is Hugh sharp our new language for
thinking about quantum algorithms at a
high level so let's go on and get
started a few sharp is a should at some
level be a familiar language there's we
can break things down into operations
functions namespaces other elements that
are familiar from other languages so for
instance if we want to run a hello world
we can do that by using the message
function to print out to a console and
once we have that we can use use that
from c-sharp in Visual Studio in a
manner very similar to you might how you
might send code to a GPU or an FPGA as
an accelerator here we'll ask for a
target machine a quantum simulator that
is something running locally on our
desktop that simulates how an ideal
quantum computer would work for small
numbers of qubits up to about 30 and we
can ask our target machine or quantum
simulator to go and run our new
operation and wait for the answer back
so if we do that we'll see a hello world
just as we expect so it's a good
hands-on way to get started with of
course a quantum programming language
wouldn't be very interesting or useful
if you couldn't allocate qubit so let's
do that we can allocate the new qubit we
can use what's called a Hadamard
operation to prepare a superposition
state on that new qubit and then if we
were to measure it
we'll get 50/50 statistics out between a
0 or 1 outcome so that makes a good
random number generator so let's
simulate how that would work well
allocate a qubit apply a Hadamard
measured the result and then that's a
result we can return back out to the
classical world
once we have that it's very similar at
the c-sharp level we can save out the
result from having run our new operation
into a variable we can loop over we can
print it to a console we can do whatever
we like with it at that point giving us
a very flexible way of interacting with
this new fun and routine so let's run it
and see what we get so we get about the
50/50 statistics we'd expect out of that
showing that that operates the way we'd
expect we can build on that and do even
more by using the other operations built
into Q sharp such as the controlled-not
operation to prepare entangled state
since instead of simply superposition
States on the single qubit so now we'll
allocate two qubits apply how to Mart to
the first prepare to prepare
superposition and then make an entangled
pair using the controlled-not operation
I mentioned earlier now when we measure
we know that because they're entangled
we'll get the same answer on both qubits
um so we will return that out to the
classical rolled pull it from c-sharp in
the same fashion and again we get the
same kinds of 50/50 stats we expect
except now correlated between the two
things to that entanglement we can also
run in Visual Studio code on not only
Windows but also Mac OS and Linux so
let's look at using the elements that we
just saw in Visual Studio here to build
up something that's actually a really
useful quantum building block as we look
at other algorithms so in particular
let's start with teleportation that's a
little bit of a whimsical name but it
really points to a very basic building
block that gets used in a lot of
different contexts with a fondant
program as a way to move information
around a quantum device so we can write
out the same things we did earlier of a
Hadamard and it controlled not to
prepare some entanglement we'll do the
opposite to unprepared some entanglement
to make a measurement that lets us move
that information will then apply a
correction based on that measurement and
we can you
standard classical techniques such as
unit testing to build up confidence that
we actually did what we intended to do
here in actually moved information
correctly so what's
run that here we can run it using
the.net core SDK the same way we'd run
anything else with C sharp or F sharp on
your favorite operating system and when
we run that we get that the state was
teleported successfully but this somehow
it feels a little bit unsatisfying as an
ending point because I had to list out
each of the individual operations and
that's great if you understand deeply
what each of those do but it really
isn't speaking to how do we get hands on
thinking at a high level about quantum
algorithms so instead Q sharp lets us do
something else which is extract those
into a new operation document them and
say it give a name to those patterns
that occur in front of programming the
same way that we might refactor code
classically and now instead of listing
Hadamard c not i say prepare some
entanglement and now the description of
teleportation says it reads more
logically in terms of what we're trying
to implement rather than how we're
trying to implement so now I can say
prepare an entangled pair adjoint says -
unprepared so that we can use that
preparation as a measurement we can then
apply the correction and we call this
operation to do teleportation as a
library routine went for a particular
state that we want to send
and I can run that in the same way
you'll see that it succeeds for the
exact same reason and once we have these
kinds of building blocks we can use them
to do some really neat things so for
instance if you're interested in
chemistry a problem you might want to
ask is given some Hamiltonian that
describes a particular chemical system
what is the ground state of that
Hamiltonian and what is the ground state
energy this is something that determines
a lot of different properties such as
reaction rates and so it's really
interesting in a lot of different
chemistry applications so let's start
with a simple h2 molecule that where we
can compare two theory and we'll
describe the initial state of a
simulation of that molecule sorry
each step of the simulation the initial
state of that simulation and the
classical techniques statistical
techniques we'll use to extract
information about the ground state and I
can run this in exactly the same sense
as I ran all of the basic building
blocks we saw earlier using the.net core
SDK and we'll see a plot that compares
on the in what we infer the ground state
energy to be from a quantum simulation
to what we know from theory for this
simple molecule giving us some
confidence again that we've built up the
simulation in a useful way so these are
some of the things you can do with the
quantum development kit and to try and
make and it's all powered by a large set
of open source libraries that form the
standard library that you can download
look at see how they work peel back the
layers and also contribute to we're very
thankful to the Q sharp community for
many of the contributions we've gotten
back into the standard library and you
can always look and see how for instance
state preparation for our betrayed
States is defined by looking at the Q
sharp source code the standard libraries
to try and help make it easier to get
hands on and learn whether you're new to
quantum entirely or whether you're a
quantum researchers looking to branch
into more programming based effort
um we've recently also released a set of
what we call kavas or self-paced
exercises to teach different concepts in
quantum programming
starting from what are the basic
operations available to a quantum
programming and ranging through more
advanced topics such as how do you
represent classical functions as
Oracle's or subroutines in a quantum
program so we really hope you'll get an
give it a try and we look forward to
your feedback thank you very much
you